welcome to a cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Joseph L in
tech America and today we'll be talking
about audit logging you can ask
questions anytime on the platform there
should be a link underneath your screen
and we have Google is on standby to
answer all of your questions so let's
get started so what are we going to
cover today first of all we're going to
cover the basics we're gonna look at
what our logs are and how you can get
them turned on then we're going to go
into some more detail ways to use audit
logs so setting up alerting exports and
storage then we're gonna look at some
advanced use cases like insider risk and
compliance and finally we'll head to
your questions so let's go to the basics
all right so to start out I'm going to
start out talking about stock driver and
you might be asking what are we talking
about stock driver for that we're here
to talk about audit logs but all audit
logs come through the stack driver
platform and specifically the stock
driver logging platform so to give you a
little bit of a overview of what stack
driver it is it is a SAS ops suite from
Google that's used by developers
operators to monitor and troubleshoot
your applications whether they're
running on TCP AWS cloud native
infrastructure wherever it's hosted and
our goal is to help you keep all of your
stuff fast available and secure so there
are a number of different tools in the
stack driver toolkit six of them
actually today we're going to be
focusing on monitoring and logging and
those are the two parts of the platform
that will allow us to visualize our
audit logs
export them different places alert on
them create charts from them all sorts
of snazzy stuff and the other tools in
the toolkit here error reporting trace
debug and profiler we're going to save
for a later date awesome so let's have a
think about all logging what what is odd
order logging it's an immutable audit
trail of all the actions taken by anyone
who interacts with your data and
I'm GCP so you can think of it as a
record of who did what where when and
why on your systems audit logs are
immutable and you get them for free for
365 days for admin audit logs or for
longer if you want to pay to have your
ingestion of your data access audit logs
so let's look in a bit more detail at
how those work admin activity audit logs
are the most basic audit logs that come
turn on for all writes by default on the
vast majority of all your GCP services
like I said we hosts in four three four
three hundred foot sorry for four
hundred days now and you can see them in
your stack driver log and console data
access audit logs are need to be turned
on you pay for ingestion for each of
these data access audit logs but you
don't pay for storage we'll cover how
you get these turned on later but what
these show is an additional bit of
information around who rip who read or
wrote data from your data sources on GCP
finally we now have access transparency
logs as well which cover actions by
Google support and engineering so
imagine a person created a bucket on
your DCP service that created an ad be
an activity order log then someone
uploaded some data into that bucket read
it looked at the the data in the bucket
a few times and created a few more data
access audit logs let's say they're
having a problem with that data and they
needed to go and get some help from
support they call up Google support and
Google support goes and looks at some of
the settings on that bucket to see if
the appropriate permissions were in
place I just want to reiterate Google
support can't look at the data that's
inside your bucket but we want to love
all of this information so that you can
you can get a full picture of your damn
security posture and GCP when the Google
Support Technician looks at the metadata
and ackles on the bucket an access
transparency log is created that you can
also see in your stackdriver login
console so let's talk about some of the
key features of these so like I said
these are available for nearly every GCP
service in the case of your admin
activity and data access audit logs our
access transparency logs are only
available on six services we just
launched them into beta or two weeks ago
well I plan to add a lot more new
services throughout the rest this year
that have auto-grade protections so
these logs are immutable once you turn
them on you can't actually delete them
and the reason for this is that we want
to make sure that if a malicious insider
inside your company is attempting to
cover their tracks
these audit logs can't be deleted by
them so you always have a record of
what's happened retention is 13 months
484 admin activity and access
transparency logs and for data access
audit logs the billing is based on
ingestion and not retention so once you
turn them on we'll charge you to ingest
them and you can decide how to whether
to export them or put them somewhere
else and we'll talk about how you can do
that later in this presentation
cool so let's look at a demo of how we
can turn audit logs aren't will switch
to a demo so what I've got open here is
just a console I've got the G Cloud SDK
installed I'm going to call get iam
policy on the project that I want to
turn data access audit logs on you'll
see that there's really no information
there's just your basic sort of iam
config what I'm going to do is I'm going
to edit that to change the iam config to
tol GCP to turn audit logs on for this
particular project so I'm going to jump
into our documentation which you can see
on our website you can look up
configuring data access audit logs on
our DCP doc site you can turn them on
for different services there's different
kinds of audit logs obviously that you
can turn on and you can also exempt
people I'm going to show you a sample
there's a little yeah more sample here
that we can pull and paste into our
config file to show you how this works
so as you can see in this little config
I've got I'm turning on audit logs for
all services in all types so admin read
data right and data read you notice is
also another audit log config object at
the bottom that creates an exemption for
a particular service account I'm gonna
go ahead and remove that because I don't
actually want to exempt anyone from
being able to write audit logs but you
might like to do that if there's a
service account that's spewing a lot of
audit logs that are not valuable to you
so I've saved this new config file I'm
going to go ahead and call set iam
policy on the same project
and success I've set the new I am config
and it shows that I've enabled audit
logs for all services and all types
admin read data right and data read
let's see how this works so I'm now
going to go ahead and check to see if
the data access or logs are turned on
for this particular project I'm going to
go into the storage bucket that I have
set up I've accessed this text file and
this is text and now I'm gonna head to
my logs and see if it shows up in my
logs we're going to stackdriver logging
and there we go I've got a get and some
list operations so pause it there before
I leak all of my personal information
okay so that is how you get data access
audit logs turned on and admin read or
logs turned on
like I said admin access right audit
logs are turned on by default if you'd
like to turn an access transparency logs
you can head to the google cloud website
just look for the access transparency
product and there's a request access
button alright so next up we have using
our audit logs I'm gonna jump into a
demo here alright and so I'm gonna go
over into my cloud console and I've got
my logs viewer up I'm going to select my
GCE VMs that's how they take a look at
all my GCE VMs so right now I'm seeing
all the logs that are coming from these
GCE VMs I just want my audit logs I'm
gonna select activity here and I don't
have anything super recent that's okay
go ahead and load some older logs here
and let's say that I get a call from
there we go
let's say I got a call from one of my
developers who says hey what's going on
my VM is gone I thought it should be
there and I say alright well what's your
VMs name and they tell me it is my VM -
so I'm going to search for my VM - in my
logs let's take a look to see what's
going on here and I'm gonna look through
all of the audit logs and see if I can
find out who took an action or if the
system took an action to get rid of this
VM here all right live demo that's
always cool looks so you know it's live
right that's alright so I can see a
number of different things going on here
but the thing that's particularly
interesting to me is I can see in these
audit logs I can see it was created on
April 8th around 11 o'clock at night and
on April 10th I can see that it was
actually deleted so let me we dive into
that specific log entry and take a look
at what's going on here
you can see there is a lot of data but
very specifically I can see somebody
called the delete the delete function on
this and I can see the principal email
is EMCO sakuga calm
oh that's me oh yeah I actually
accidentally deleted this this person's
young but we have a log entry of that so
we know exactly who took which entry so
that's all nice but let's one of the
common use cases we hear from our
customers is they don't want to just be
able to use it for Diagnostics purposes
but they also want to be able to create
proactive alerts on certain types of
audit logs so a common thing that we
hear maybe is
users who want to maybe create an
alerting policy anytime a user is added
to a new iam role when they're outside
of their organization so it's kind of
complicated but that's ok we can handle
it let's start out with going to our I
am section here and I'll open that in a
new tab and I'm going to just to kind of
test this out add a new member audit
logs rock at gmail.com
all righty and I'm gonna select a role
for this and grant them a role so we're
gonna go ahead and save and I'm gonna go
back to my logs and take a look to see
if I can can see what happened there no
there's something to do with audit logs
Rock now when I search that oh look I'm
searching through my DC EVM instances
which isn't actually where I want to be
looking so I'm gonna have convert to the
advanced filter here and I can see I
have a more advanced query language that
I can interact with so rather than look
for everything just on my on my GCE
instances I'm gonna look for audit logs
rock across everything and here I can
see that we recently added audit logs
rock to a said I am policy and I can see
kind of the details here so I'm gonna go
ahead and click can show matching
entries I always want this just to be
limited to my audit logs so I'll add
that into my filter and then I might
also want to say I don't want to limit
it just to audit logs Rock but let me
find out exactly where that is so I'm
gonna look into here and my service data
policy Delta my binding deltas and I can
see the member who is added here is
audit logs rock at gmail.com
so if I click show matching entries for
just a moment I can change this my so
that I exclude anything so I'm adding my
not here that matches user : and then
I'm gonna say my organization is at
google.com let me try it making sure we
still see the right audit log there
alright good so
that's appropriate from here I can in
one step just create a metric so what
this will do is for any new log entries
coming in we will check what logs based
metrics we actually have and if it
matches any will count that so will be
basically be counting any incoming log
entries that match this filter so I'm
going to name it blogs from outside my
org and that's it I'm gonna go ahead and
create the metric there are some more
advanced things you can do with logs
based metrics but we'll save that for a
different day and you can see this is
actually my second log space metric here
and now what I want to do is actually
create an alerting policy from it so
what I just created was logs from
outside of my org I'm gonna go ahead and
create an alert from this metric so this
is popping up the stack driver
monitoring console remember we said
there are two different tools within
stackdriver that we're going to be using
one is monitoring what the other is
logging also if you recall we said log
based metrics will only apply for data
going forward so we just created this
log space metric we won't see any data
here that's okay
and but I want to say I want to be
alerted anytime this happens so if I see
even one ever I want I want to be
alerted for that and we'll say across
any resource I'm gonna go ahead and save
the alerting condition so this is a
stack driver monitoring alerting UI the
way it works is we're going to define
these conditions if those conditions are
violated then will automatically create
an incident and send some notification
so the next thing we need to do is
choose what notifications we need to
send here so we have a number of
different notification options email our
cloud console mobile app some other
commonly used ones our web hooks slack
and pager duty
in this case I'll leave it at a male and
I will send it to audit logs Rock at
gmail.com I could add another
notification if I want it I can add some
documentation someone added a policy
outside our org go talk to them
I could link to a playbook here as well
and then I can name the policy so alert
if users outside my org I'll go ahead
and save my policy all right so now
let's go ahead and test it I'm gonna go
back to our I am page over here and I'm
gonna go ahead and test this again by
adding another member
so audit let's Rocke gmail.com alrighty
and I'll set a random other I am role
and save that it should take us just a
minute to for that alerting policy to
fire so while we're doing that let's go
ahead and talk about another common use
case that we hear from customers which
is great it's fantastic that we can
alert on our audit logs but what I
really want to also be able to do is to
do some automation based on our audit
logs and so here's where the power of
the stackdriver blogging platform is
really powerful so we're gonna start out
with what we're gonna do is we're going
to take those audit logs that are coming
in we're going to export the matching
logs that we care about to a pub sub
Channel and we'll use cloud functions to
take action based on that so again the
kind of flow is audit logs are
automatically generated that's fantastic
they'll come in to stock driver logging
from there they will go to this log sync
that we need to create and then from
there they'll go to pub/sub we use cloud
functions to do whatever kind of crazy
processing we dream
so for this example let's say every time
we start up a new VM we want to apply a
label or maybe check to see if that
label exists and if it doesn't then
automatically apply that label for
example say that the environment is prod
so the first thing we need to go ahead
and do is create an export so you'll see
over here we we started out in the logs
viewer wherein we tested out logs
metrics that was our that was how we
created alerting policies from there
we're going to do export so I'm gonna go
over into our exports tab if a couple of
exports already set up here similar to
how logs based metrics work exports also
work only kind of going forward for log
entries and so right before this I did
create the log sync just to make sure
that everything works so I'm gonna go
ahead and take a look at that log sync
and what I'm saying is I want anything
the colon here there's a substring match
so anything where the log name matches
my activity logs and anything where the
audit logging proto payload method name
is insert and that's the kind of keyword
that you'll see in our Doc's is used
when a new VM is created and I also want
to make sure that we actually have the
type that this colon star means this
field exists so if I load I haven't
created anything recently but let me go
ahead and load some order logs here and
take a look and we can see some examples
of this as I've spun up in testing some
different logs so you can see I created
my VM one my VM 2 my BM 3 each of these
you know already happened back in time
but if I create the next one my VM 4
then it should automatically show up
here on the sink alright so I have my
sink working from here I'm actually
going to go to cloud functions so one
other thing I wanted to call out here
for just a moment
the other important thing
about this sink is where it actually
goes so if I added the sink one last
time I had to specify the filter I also
had to specify the location so I chose
cloud pub/sub my options were a bigquery
cloud storage and pub/sub this custom
destination will allow you to create an
export to a different location so like
for example to a different project or
even to a different work if you really
wanted to and your permissions were set
up correctly bigquery and pub/sub happen
in real time cloud storage is batched
about once per hour and so it takes a
few hours for those logs to show up in
that location and we'll talk about why
you might want to use these other export
locations in a minute here but we'll
focus on cloud pub/sub for right now and
as soon as one size chose cloud pub/sub
i had the option to either use an
existing pub/sub feed audit log pub/sub
or to create a new one so i'm going to
use the one i already have created here
so now i'm gonna go over to my cloud
functions alright in creating the cloud
function took a little bit of thought so
I've done that ahead of time here and
then you can see I've got this cloud
function called process audit logs I'm
gonna go ahead and click on it I can see
in the last hour there it hasn't had to
process anything at all here if i zoom
out for a few days we should probably
see yep I processed a few things a
couple of days ago and one not that long
ago just to make sure everything was
still working I can take a look at the
trigger so you can set cloud functions
up to trigger on different things in
this case we're triggering on the audit
log pub/sub topic that we had specified
in our log sync now let's take a look at
the source all right so what this cloud
function is going to do is act on a
pubsub message we know that the log
entries are what it will be coming in on
that pub/sub message so we're going to
parse that pub/sub message take a look
at the log entry here we have some off
stuff that I took from our handy
examples in our
documentation and then we're gonna check
to make sure that this is actually a
valid blog entry for us in this case we
only care about new VM so only things
where it is actually a log entry and
there is actually a request field and
the method name of that request field is
compute instances insert and then will
actually pull the name of the VM out of
there and in order to add a label to
that VM we need to first get the excuse
me get the labels that exist on that VM
already and then we can add new ones if
needed and so that's what we're doing
here we're doing a get on that new VM
logging things if we see an error we
have to pull out that fingerprint and
that's what we use to actually create
the new label down here we're
environment is prod and then we'll say
yay we set the labels and exit out of
here so with that let's go ahead and go
back to our compute console and I'm
going to create a new instance alright
and I'll call this my VM for go ahead
and set it as a small one we'll go ahead
and create it so it'll take just a
moment for that to spin up and I should
be able to see it in my audit logs let's
hop over to the logs viewer here and I'm
going to go back to all my logs and let
me switch to the basic mode alright and
so now again I'm seeing all my logs from
all of my VMs instead I'm just gonna
take a look at my audit logs let's see
and indeed I see that a new instance my
VM for was inserted just a moment ago
so now I can go back to my cloud
function and we'll take a look at the
cloud function and what it's processed
and you can see oh yeah it did see
something just a moment ago so you
should really have left the tab open but
that's alright go back to compute engine
here take a look at my VM for and you'll
remember I didn't add any labels
whenever I created this so if I want to
make sure that this worked correctly
info panel and we can see it worked we
created a key with environment and the
value is fraud so you can use this for
lots of different things if if I were
well instant firewall rule is
incorrectly configured you know
automatically remove that or you know
again if we think about the example we
just did with our alerting if someone
adds a user who isn't part of the
organization maybe change the role that
was just created the kind of
possibilities here are endless because
we have so many different api's that you
can use so speaking of the thing that we
were alerting on let's just hop over to
the email for audit logs Rock and we can
see we should have received an email
saying hey there was an issue and indeed
I had created a previous alerting policy
so you see it represented a few times
here but I can drill into this and it
does let me know that the alerting
policy was created that that the issue
was detected here great so moving along
then that was alerting and creating
exports I mentioned there are a few
different types of exports another type
of export that you might choose to use
is bigquery and so I have if I go to my
exports I can see a number of I've
created this thing for my bigquery audit
logs and I could use bigquery to
actually explore the logs here as well
let's see and then the last thing that I
want to show is suppose I wanted to send
all of my logs are all of my audit logs
to GCS for compliance purposes I could
use a log sync for that as well
so same sort of process would hold here
I would choose which logs I want to
export and in this case here I'll export
all of my logs from all of my BMS my GCE
VMs and I'll select a new storage
location I have to create a new one all
GCE GCE logs and I can then there we go
go ahead and create this and that way
all my future logs will will be put into
that location the thing that we hear
from customers a lot though is all right
that's cool but I have an organization
with thousands of projects what if I
need to how do I make sure that I have
log things set up on all of them and so
we have a really cool tool called
aggregated exports which will allow you
to manage that so what a great iudex
ports will allow you to do and you can
do this via the API or via the g-cloud
command line interface is I can create a
log sync either at the folder or at the
organization level and if I say include
children then it will not only get the
logs from all of the VMs that I have or
all of the projects that I have today
but also from any new project that's
spun up in the future alright and with
that let's move on to advanced use cases
Joe so Mary's looked at some of the ways
that we can set up alerting and exports
and storage let's look at some of the
use cases that we might use those in so
the first one we have is insider risk
audits
so we all have sensitive data in our
businesses we all want to make sure it's
protected but obviously we need people
to actually go and use that data from
time to time so what if you want to put
a little bit of an extra bit of security
on top of that and audit some of those
accesses that are particularly sensitive
so let's say that you receive in the
security team tip-off that one of your
employees has been looking up customer
data that a legitimate business purpose
you might have all of your storage
systems inside GCP you've configured
data access audit logging and it's
piping and all into stackdriver logging
as Mary showed you you can set up
exports so you can export them into an
external sim tool that's how you'd like
to view your data or you can even export
them into bigquery if you prefer to use
bigquery once you've done that you can
search for an actor using the principal
email field you can audit all the
resources that that person has accessed
in the last you know seven days or month
however long it is you're auditing their
their behavior and then in some cases
you can even go ahead and order the full
request and response strings which we
have available and a lot of our order
locks so you can get a true picture of
exactly what people have been doing on
your service
for compliance
we often have companies contacting us
talking about how they need to retain
audit logs to comply with whatever
policy or regulation that that they're
subject to for this you might enable all
the audit logs on all of your services
for example that would go into stack
travel log in and then you would
configure your export this time into
just a GCS bucket and you might
configure the IAM policy on that GCS
bucket to be highly restricted so only
someone maybe in your legal team can
access it and then also you would enable
data access or logging on that bucket
itself to make sure that you have an
audit trail of who has been accessing
the audit logs from that you can
generate reports from your logs turn
them over to auditors or retain them for
a custom period you can retain them for
how long you want in your GCS bucket one
other cool feature that we didn't talk
about but just kind of to call out here
and is we have a feature called logging
exclusions so if you want to store those
logs in a GCS bucket but you don't want
to pay for those in stock driver logging
specifically for those data access logs
which can be really high of volume
you can use your export along with the
feature called exclusions and say like
keep those logs out of stock driver
logging because the export happens
before the exclusion those those will
still be exported well you can choose
not to pay for them in stock driver
logging if you want those for compliance
purposes but don't need them for
alerting or kind of other stock driver
related functionality searching etc cool
great okay so stay tuned for some live
Q&A we'll be back in less than a minute
to answer your questions
you
okay and we're back thanks for asking
all these amazing questions we're going
to go ahead and answer a few of them now
so the first one is what if I want to
delete my audit logs and not be charged
for them great question we get this one
a lot so the answer is that audit logs
are charged only based on logs or charge
only based on ingestion so you don't
need to worry about managing the volume
of data that is being stored and I'll
also remind folks that we only charge
for the data access logs or the access
transparency logs not for the admin
activity logs which are available kind
of free of charge as part of your use of
of the Google cloud platform one other
thing I'd like to add there is just
around deleting projects so as you'd
imagine when you delete a project it
will delete the information around that
project and that will include the logs
that are inside your project so do make
sure that you have the appropriate
controls in place to prevent that from
happening if that's something you'd like
to avoid so the next question is can I
write my own or it logs so we do support
via the logging API writing all sorts of
different logs audit logs are kind of a
special type of log that we've defined
and we write to them on B on your behalf
as part of Google cloud platform so you
can write your own audit logs per se but
you can create your own logs that do
anything else you want to capture there
and we support that the API we also have
a logging agent you can send that
through our client libraries so there
are lots of different ways to get your
own logs into the stock driver logging
platform great what actual information
is contained inside the audit logs do
you have the location of the access ur
this is a really good question so you
can read about all the information
that's contained inside the audit logs
on our Google cloud platform audit
logging documentation page there's
different types of information inside
each of the three different types of
logs so in your admin access API logs
there's more information around people
who
formed things like as Mary was showing
you before creation and deletion of
objects and so forth new data access
logs you're gonna get more information
about a resource that was read or
written to in the access transparency
logs you get similar information however
you do get a slightly less information
that while in your admin activity and
data access logs you will get the
principal email of the actor in your
access transparency log so you won't get
the principal email of the of the Google
employee who performing access but you
will get the location of where they
access it from unfortunately don't have
that information available yet inside
our admin activity or data access logs
but if it's of interest to you please
feel free to reach out to us we'd love
to hear from you and with with respect
to the access transparency logs as well
when we show you the location of the
Google bar we also show you the desk
location where that Googler is typically
situated so you'll be able to see that
the Googler was in the US at the time
but their dislocation is typically in
Canada that's something that we've heard
from some customers being helpful for
compliance reasons but your mileage may
vary but if we have any customers who
are concerned about capturing the
location of the access ur for other logs
that generally isn't something we have
sure right that's right yes and last
question our audit logs available for
all our services what they're available
for almost all of our services we're
hopefully hopefully going to be able to
announce later this year they are
available for all of our services right
now you can head to our Google cloud
platform documentation to see the full
list of services that have logs
available for them and also you can read
what the state of those are or logging
integrations are so some cases there may
be in GA for some other cases we may be
only producing them in beta so you might
not be able to rely on them as much as
you can for a GA style audit log however
you can be fairly confident that for
most services by the end of this year we
should have audit logging coverage at
least for admin activity and data access
audit logging with respect to the admin
excuse me the access transparency logs
those are only available for six
services at the moment they're available
on Google Cloud Storage Google App
Engine I am
key management service persistent disk
and arrested them all I gave the full
list is available online you can go and
head to our Google cloud platform
products page and read on the access
transparency product page which services
they're available for we're constantly
adding new services to our access
transparency integrations we have
another for coming this quarter and
we're gonna have a lot more added this
year so stay tuned if you're interested
in that you can definitely take a look
at our website and if if you want we can
turn them on for you one thing I will
note that I don't think we've had a
chance to say it though with respect to
the access transparency logs is that you
will need to have gold or platinum
support enabled to turn those on once
you have gold and platinum support
enabled you can turn access transparency
logs on and will collect and store those
logs for you free of charge but
unfortunately we don't yet offer this
service to customers who are who and who
don't have those support packages
enabled okay I think that's all we have
question wise as always you know where
to contact us you can get more support
from Google support but otherwise thanks
so much for participating in this
webinar we hope you've had an amazing
journey on this order logging journey
with us please tune in next Tuesday for
the next episode of cloud live on air
and thanks very much
you